اذا الجيش الاسرائيلي كان قد اعلن اليوم
عن عمليه انزال جوي للعتاد والسلاح وايضا
الغذاء والوقود لقواته في منطقه فوق خان
يونس لعل هذه العمليه هي الخامسه منذ
بدايه الحرب ولكن تعد المره الثانيه بعد
ان كان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد قام بعمليه
انزال في الحا من ديسمبر واعتبرت الاولى
منذ حربه على لبنان عام 2000
وسته عمليه الانزال لها كثير من الدلالات
بالنظر ايضا الى ما تصلنا من اخبار متعلقه
بالاشتباكات اشتباكات ومواجهات على اكثر
من صعيد لعلنا نشير الى المناطق الغربيه
وايضا وسط خان يونس الاشتباكات وقعت
بالتحديد في منطقه البلد وتحديدا في
المحطه والكتيبه ولكن ايضا كان هناك
اشتباكات عنيفه في محيط مستشفى ناصر وسط
خان يونس ياتي ذلك بينما ايضا كتائب
القسام كانت قد اعلنت عن
استهداف تجمعين للجنود في جنوبي وشرق خان
يونس استهداف دبابات من نوع ميركافا وذلك
بقذائف الياسين وايضا استهداف قوات الرجله
اذا جبه تان في خان يونس سواء في ناحيه
الغرب او وسط خان يونس اضافه الى
الجنوب فيها اشتباكات تخضها المقاومه مع
القوات الاسرائيليه لو ذهبنا الى المنطقه
الوسطى المنطقه الوسطى وتحديدا ربما اخر
الاخبار التي اعلنتها القسام هنا في مخيم
المغازي المغازي الذي تعرض الى عمليات قصف
خلال اليومين الماضيين بالقنابل
الفوسفوريه القسام اعلنت عن اشتباكات
خاضها مقاوميها مع القوات الاسرائيليه
واعلنت عن تدمير ست دبابات من نوع ميركافا
بشكل كلي في مخيم المغازي بل واعلنت ايضا
عن عمليه قنص واستهداف لنحو 11 جنديا في
مخيم المغازي اذا المنطقه الوسطى ايضا هي
محور لهذه الاشتباكات سواء كان في الجنوب
او ايضا في المنطقه الوسطى مع عمليه قصف
متواصله على مختلف مخيمات المنطقه الوسطى
لو ذهبنا الى المنطقه الشماليه ولعل
التطور اللافت في هذه المنطقه هو هذه
الاشتباكات ايضا التي نقلها مراسل لنا عاد
الحديث عن هذه المناطق هنا ابراج الكرامه
وابراج المخابرات ولكن ايضا الاشتباكات
العنيفه في جباليا جباليا امس كانت مسرحا
لاشتباكات عنيفه تخضها المقاومه على هذا
المحور ولكن ايضا عمليه قصف مكثف
لمواقع المقاومه هنا في مخيم جبليه اذا
على صعود عديده تتطور عمليه القصف ايضا
استهدفت منطقه الميناء
وايضا منطقه الدرج حيث كان هناك استشهاد
لنحو 25 فلسطينيا اذا زين على جبهات
متعدده في الشمال والوسط والجنوب ولكن ل
على ابرزها هذه الاخبار التي تاتي من خان
يونس